pierre thibault et président de la
nouvelle association des barbares
bonsoir monsieur thibault bonsoir je
finis comment ça s'est passé et ses
opérations de surveillance en fin de
semaine mais premièrement la démarche de
madame guilbeault est une stratégie qui
était très efficace donc le disait 2200
visite plusieurs membres des visites
très courtoise des corps policiers
je pense que tout le monde était à
l'affût sa fin de semaine ça vient peut
donner encore plus de profondeur aux
mesures qui sont mises en place par les
établissements
en parallèle avec le gouvernement et les
ministres sociaux on a eu je pense une
opération efficace à voir si on peut
continuer à quelques reprises de
continuer à faire de la sensibilisation
ça serait peut-être une des prochaines
années étudiées pour éviter la fermeture
de l'économie qui provient du secteur
des bars et de la restauration au québec
ces interventions vous les voyez comme
de la sensibilisation auprès de la
clientèle et auprès des bars une partie
de sensibilisation mais il ya aussi une
partie je pense qu'ils viennent
confirmer l'ampleur et la gravité de la
situation puis surtout les codes et
l'inca donc les seuls et uniques mouton
noir qui est vienne perturber toutes les
statistiques sont maintenant épié et
surveiller autant par nous les
propriétaires d'abord que par les corps
policiers par le gouvernement est-ce que
ça fait fuir votre client terre est ce
que ça fait peur à votre clientèle que
ces interventions policières n'ont
vraiment pas puis ça rame un peu l'image
des bardes en temps si vous permettez à
près de 2000 bars au québec présentement
pour des retombées de 760 millions de
dollars dont chuck et 2000 bars 760
millions va aimer leur foyer
l'idée c'est que on travaille tous
ensemble et quand policiers sont
présents dans nos établissements
une deux fois par année présentement on
voit qu'elle recule de sang ce qui est
logique donc les clients eux veulent
continuer à travers la morosité et la
grisaille de cette crise je crois avoir
des activités sociales et nous ce qu'on
dit c'est qu'on n'est pas en mesure
d'encadrer les gens et des dix
départements avec leur maman donc aucune
moi je dirais bien entre de ma
connaissance chez nous à l'habitude les
membres j'ai eu aucun
témoignage comme quoi il y aurait eu une
mauvaise expérience tant du côté des
bars des propriétaires que des clients
un des policiers ont jugé compliqué
avait eu des infractions puis on est ni
un signifie soit 90 qui demanderont 4%
de taux qui est encore trop pour nous
faut éliminer tout ça donc merci quoi
dire de plus que remercie la place en
fin de semaine donc merci au
gouvernement
vous préférez ça que de voir vos
établissements fermés en même temps
beaucoup de gens sont d'avis que l'on
devrait compte tenu de la hausse des cas
présentement fermée tous les endroits
qui sont plus problématiques que dorothy
bien sûr on pense au bar est ce que ça
serait pas une solution de fermer
temporairement de vous aider entre temps
écoutez je crois que la situation
économique présentement et précaires
puis la base de cette réflexion là c'est
surtout au niveau de la santé publique
une star d'astarté fermer les bars on le
fait rapidement les retombées comme je
disais c'est 760 millions avec les
rapports bi fiscal on est au milliard de
dollars par année dans l'industrie débat
sur douze mois c'est 85 millions par
mois qui dans les kits injectés dans
l'économie du québec
cela dit je ne veux pas négliger du tout
la portion santé publique
je crois que le gouvernement est
conscient fonds d'aidé s'ils prennent
des décisions présentement pour éviter
la catastrophe économique tout en
préservant la sécurité publique comme
vous le disiez vous permettez la majeure
partie vient des rassemblements privé
présentement je crois que le nerf de la
guerre pour la santé publique se trouve
dans les rassemblements privé où il ya
aucune balise nous on veut aider le
gouvernement à cheval baliser les
activités sociales de là où l'on croit
être en mesure de gérer encore une fois
la population par contre sur une
fermeture unilatérale ou 1re confinement
général en oeuvre on ne créera aucune
obstruction dans le sens où tous les
commerces de détail sont appelés à
fermer pour une prévention mesures
d'urgence ont suivi un retour avec un
chiffre inouï exactement on attend avec
monsieur foot gay bien à quelques
reprises la dette mais quelque chose qui
traitent l'eau par l'entreprise
présentement je pense particulièrement
boîtes de nuit que l'adn même de ces
places là c'est 18 heures à 4 heures du
matin que présentement sont déjà sur le
suroît
l'expression pour maintenant je crois
qu'il faut aller de mesures économiques
sont sans arrêt des subventions mais on
étudie plusieurs scénarios on a la
chance de parler d'économie est ce que
ce serait des allégements fiscaux des
crédits d'impôts écoutez tout et tout
est en discussion je crois que
présentement ils veulent maîtriser la
crise santé publique sécurité pour
éventuellement arriver avec un scénario
au niveau de l'économie
après cette crise là parce qu'un
effondrement du système économique n'est
pas plus bon socialement à la sortie
d'une crise en temps dans une trousse
pas en discussion mais oui notre direct
ça serait bienvenu surtout pour nos
membres sont dans le secteur des boîtes
de nuit parce que vous envisagez aussi
la saison froide le sist un peu plus
risqué de ce temps ci un moment donné on
va vraiment fermé les terrasses on
présume que ça va avoir un impact
de toute évidence sur vos activités
c'est clair si je dis n'importe quel
entrepreneur qui est ne fait que 50 % sa
capacité de chefs d'affaires se retrouve
avec 50 % des déficits donc ça ce serait
comme calcul d'un autre côté on est
appuyée par des mesures fédérales
présentement que le salariat cycle
commercial
je sais que le ministère des
communications québec fait beaucoup de
pression pour reconduire ces enveloppes
le jusqu'en décembre
on aimerait avoir une réponse justement
du fédéral assez rapidement parce que
des gens qui n'ont pas le choix comme
vous le savez dans le nuit au torpédo
real il ya un moment où on doit prendre
la décision à ce que je continue
l'endettement est ce que je peux
poursuivre sur un taux d'endettement
sociaux ou si je dois fermer boutique
donc on a besoin de confirmation il de
se faire rassurer temps où aimé y
retourne au québec avec le c'est ce
qu'on verra il ya un discours du trône
cette semaine il ya beaucoup d'attentes
face à tout cela pierre thibault merci
mais ça vous bonne soirée